U GREW UP.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T KNOW MY
STORY.
BUT THE WAY I GREW UP, WE HAD A
LOT OF STRUGGLES.
FACED A LOT OF CHALLENGES.
EIGHT AND A HALF YEARS AGO, LIKE
SIX MONTHS BEFORE I CAME TO THE
LEAGUE, WE WERE TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WHERE WE'RE GOING TO GET MY
NEXT MEAL FROM.
I SAW MY PARENTS EVERY DAY
SACRIFICE, WORK EXTREMELY HARD
TO PROVIDE FOR US.
YOU KNOW, AND GROWING UP, I
ALWAYS WANTED MY -- MY FAMILY TO
HAVE A BETTER LIFE FOR THEM.
I WANTED MY BROTHERS TO HAVE A
BETTER LIFE THAN ME.
AND I WANTED MY NEXT -- MY KIDS
TO HAVE A BETTER LIFE THAN WHAT
I HAD.
SO I WORKED EXTREMELY HARD.
WHEN I DIME THE LEAGUE, I SAID
I'M 18 YEARS OLD.
NOBODY BELIEVES IN ME.
NOBODY THINKS I CAN MAKE IT.
I'M GOING TO WORK EXTREMELY HARD
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
I'M GOING TO WAKE UP EVERY DAY
WITH A GOAL IN MY MIND.
YOU KNOW, IT MIGHT BE A CRAZY
GOAL.
BUT I'M GOING TO HAVE THE GOAL
IN MY MIND AND I'M GOING TO DO
WHATEVER IT POSSIBLY TAKES TO
ACHIEVE THAT GOAL.
IF I HAVE TO STAY IN THE GYM,
SIX HOUR, EIGHT HOURS, 10 HOURS.
IF I HAVE TO RUN MORE THAN THE
OTHER GUYSINGS, NOBODY WHAT WHAT
I HAVE TO DO, I'M GOING TO DO.
IT STEP BY STEP THINGS WERE JUST
HAPPENING.
I GOT STRONGER.
I HAD PEOPLE THAT BELIEVED IN
ME.
I HAD PEOPLE PUSHED ME THROUGH
THE WHOLE JOURNEY.
I WAS SEEING THINGS -- I WAS
SEEING THINGS.
OK THIS PUDSLE OF LIFE, IT'S
COMING TOGETHER NOW.
I CAN -- I CAN ACHIEVE.
THIS AND I NEVER STOPPED
WORKING.
EVEN NOW THIS HOW MESSED UP MY
BRAIN IS.
EVEN THOUGH TODAY THAT WE WON
THE NBA CHAMPIONSHIP, I WASN'T
IN THE TEAM PHOTO.
I WENT IN THE BACK, AND I JUST
HAD TO SIT DOWN, TALK TO MY
BROTHER AS LITTLE BIT AND I WAS
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT, YOU KNOW,
WHEN WE'RE GOING TO COME BACK,
WHEN WE'RE GOING TO DO IT AGAIN.
AND YOU KNOW THAT TEASE MINDSET,
I HAVE.
AND THAT'S WHO I AM.
AND THAT'S WHAT MADE ME GREAT
THAT'S WHAT MADE THIS TEAM
GREAT.
I'M GOING TO KEEP, YOU KNOW, TRY
TO STAY HUNL AND KEEP AS YOU
SAID WHEN YOU GET TO THAT TOP OF
THAT MOUNTAIN COME GET WHAT YOU
HAVE.
AND, BUT ATTEND OF THE DAY, EVEN
IF THEY GET IT, IT'S OK.
BUT I'M GOING TO WORK.
I HAVE A L